the U.S Supreme Court issued a highly
anticipated order to preserve legal
access across most of the country to the
widely used abortion pill mythopristone
Justice Samuel Alito and Clarence Thomas
were the only two publicly dissenting
votes
the decision from the conservative
majority court is a temporary victory
for the Biden Administration and leaves
in place the fda's 23-year-old approval
of the drug while a lower court
challenge plays out
in its essential Justice Alito wrote
there were legitimate doubts the bite
Administration would obey an unfavorable
order Democratic lawmakers are
applauding the decision but the ruling
has drawn a muted response from Top
Republicans Willie James Inman reports
from Washington Willie good morning
good morning Jeff access to the abortion
pill Memphis Stone will remain in place
at least for now following a series of
legal orders and a decision by the U.S
Supreme Court
any funny a ruling the Supreme Court
allowed continued access to mifepristone
without restrictions the decision puts
lower court orders on pause while a
legal battle plays out earlier this
month Trump appointed federal judge
Matthew casmerick issued an order
blocking the fda's approval of the drug
an appeals court later struck down the
full ban but put up limits on access the
Biden Administration and the
manufacturer of mythical Stone launched
an emergency appeal to the high court we
are prepared also for a long legal
battle that is our commitment and our
promise to the millions of women across
the country the White House has embraced
the legal fight for abortion access
following the ruling President Biden
released a statement saying that he
stands by the fda's quote independent
expert authority to review approve and
regulate a wide range of prescription
drugs the decision was the most
significant case on abortion brought
before the Court's conservative majority
which struck down Roe versus Wade last
June
more than 5 million women have used the
pills since it was approved in 2000 the
uncertainty around Memphis Stone has
caused some doctors to stockpile the
medication well it really judges
should not be making medical decisions
for individuals or decisions about the
safety of a medication they don't have
the background for it a lawyer
representing the group that filed the
initial challenge to the fda's approval
of Memphis Stone said the fight is not
over regardless of how the Supreme Court
rules they're not necessarily ruling on
the merits and we're going to go right
back to the fifth Circuit Court of
Appeals
the fifth Circuit Court of Appeals is
set to hear arguments in this case next
month and there's the possibility that
it could make its way back to the
justices at the Supreme Court who could
then rule on the merits of the case Jeff
Willie James Inman thank you very much